this is worth it trailer introduction
take one all right I'm gonna try to
explain what's happening and eat ice
cream at the same time and drive what's
up guys so I'm here with Andrew Adam you
see is Adam you had a nice big lick
there we're back for season three we've
been spending the next they're gonna get
you're worth it pants on and we'll take
them right off you don't get this soon
we're gonna have to get more ice cream
so take 30 hey guys worth it is back
with a sneaker it's new
hey guys Werth is back with a season
three we have shot 10 brand new episodes
which start airing 8:00 a.m. Sunday
August 27 so roll flip guys we'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're serving fried chicken by kicking
dr. cavea the salinity and oceanic grind
eNOS of the caviar just perfect for
white meat don't think about the food of
the migration and southern food silver
of the star LeBlanc been around for over
a hundred and fifty so are you presently
creating wine that will hundred years in
the future
then also turn into this wine yeah it's
the one that no one will drink whilst
I'm a lot basically this show is like
really slowed us we're walking back from
eating up a lobster stuffed with mac and
cheese in trouble and you have to smell
wine before you drink even wine pay your
[Music]
turkey Oh
you